good morning everyone
oh good afternoon its little long day
already my name is Dominic price I'm the
product lead for storage of databases on
the Google cloud platform very exciting
very excited to speak to you guys today
about how to scale your idea your ideas
from concept to petabyte the goal of
this talk is really to give you a
overview of our storage offerings at our
databases and to give you a set of
reference architectures that you can use
when you're considering how to build
your applications these are not
prescriptive these are just some things
to give you an idea of how people are
structuring these things so that when
you are getting ready to bring your
applications to Google cloud you've got
a starting point I want to start by
talking about the Google Data Platform
so when we talk about the data platform
we really think of it in a very holistic
way we don't think about individual
products or silos of data the idea here
is that we have an integrated no-ops
cloud data platform that allows you to
build your applications and most
importantly it's about you bringing your
data to the Google cloud platform and
the way that makes sense for you and
then us making sure that we offer you
tools that allow you to move transform
and derive value from your data
regardless of where it is in the
platform a very good example of this is
making sure we talked a lot about
machine learning where are you gonna
store your training data and all of that
information has to be in the platform
somewhere and so how do you go about
doing that
so as a level set let's talk about the
portfolio of storage offerings and
databases first of all the one that most
people know about is Google Cloud
storage so this is our object storage
system it's designed for both structured
and unstructured data and we use it
people use it obviously for serving
static content like images and video but
it's also used for archival backups as
and as an intermediate data location for
data processing jobs once we get into
the databases are our oldest offering an
original offering or one of our earliest
offerings is cloud sequel so if you need
a manage my
cool solution again no ops you spin up
an instance and you have a database
cloud sequel is the solution for you
this is really useful if you're using a
web framework or some existing
application that requires my sequel or
some other off-the-shelf our DBMS and by
already been asked to be a relational
database management system if you want a
no sequel solution and our want to go
down that path we offer two solutions
one is cloud datastore cloud datastore
really serves the documents or use use
case in our platform so it's great for
mobile applications web applications if
you have a lot of JSON data this is a
great place where you can basically
start from scratch and scale up your
application the other no sequel
application that is our newest is cloud
BigTable it's currently in beta this is
a wide column store that provides a
HBase client compatibility for you to
build your analytics applications this
is really great for time series data
metrics data things like advertising
technology financial services and
Internet of Things if you get a chance
tomorrow to attend the talk by f is
about BigTable I highly encourage it
really compelling use case that they've
been able to use it for and the last one
is cache so if you need an in-memory key
value store App Engine memcache is our
solution to allow you to put a caching
layer in front of your application
commonly this is used in web mobile and
gaming applications great so how do I
get started so if you have an idea and
you want to prototype it or build
something that you can share how would I
do that so the simplest architecture
that you can put together is a set of
clients and this just might be yourself
for one or two friends and if you go
down generally we see our developers
split into two different use cases
either they feel very familiar with my
sequel and relational databases or they
want to develop no sequel solutions and
so I'm going to talk about both use
cases so that we can talk about those as
architecture well start with no sequel
so the simplest thing you can do is spin
up an app engine application and store
your application data in
data store and your static data in cloud
storage and so this should allow you
with almost no configuration to get up
and running storing data that you can
share it back to a web application or a
mobile application just as a prototype
now if you wanted to go down the
relational database path the way that
you do this is you would spin up compute
engine to use whatever framework you
want now this could be node and we just
introduced node and App Engine this
could be Python Django if you're a
Python developer it could be WordPress
that you're running on a compute engine
instance and then you would again set up
a cloud sequel so you actually have to
think a little bit you have to set up an
instance pick a size and tell us how
much storage you want and then you would
use cloud storage just like you would
with the other solution to store your
static content so this can literally go
from zero to serving applications in an
hour
right this is the simplest way that you
can get up and running on Google cloud
and start serving data now if you take
that concept and you're like oh this is
interesting and I want to scale it out
and start to move it to production and
share it with more than just me and a
couple friends you start to start
getting more complicated architectures
if you're going down to my sequel path
good news is App Engine and datastore
will just scale for you you don't have
to make any changes you just send it
more traffic store more data and it'll
scale for you same thing for cloud
storage these are fully managed leave it
and forget it type applications that
allow you to scale up so your
architecture is very similar for the no
sequel path if you're going down the
relational database path and you need to
scale and let's just assume you have
more traffic that you can put through a
single VM you would put a Google cloud
load balancer there's a couple talks
that would've happened today about this
in front of several VMs running
WordPress Jango node rails whatever
framework you Happiny running and then
speaking back to cloud sequel now with
cloud sequel when you set it up if you
are running in a production environment
you add a failover instance and that
failover instance gives you high
availability so again in a fully managed
way we'll give you a multi instance my
sequel cluster a set of replicas that
handle failover and if for some reason
there's an issue with one of you
or with your primary cloud sequel
instance we will fail over to the
failover replica so that you'll have no
downtime this is all done with a couple
of clicks when you set up your my sequel
instance again cloud storage for all
your static content really the bedrock
of all of these architectures for your
static content great so now I've gotten
up to a gigabyte of data I've got a
bunch of data in my system and what am I
going to do now so if you are continuing
to go down the our DBMS path if you've
got my sequel running you now have lots
of websites and lots of apps all talking
to your application so one thing again
cloud load balancer and you could do
this with H a proxy or and or whatever
your favorite load balancer is but if
you're in the manage world where you
want Google to manager for you and take
advantage of our amazing site
reliability engineering organization
then you would use the cloud load
balancer to put in front of your VMs
again to shard your request traffic to
the various compute pieces and then go
down to the cloud sequel level now cloud
sequel it starts to get more interesting
once you get above the amount of traffic
that you can put through a single VM
then you have to start thinking about
how to shard your traffic and this is
where my sequel starts you have to take
advantage of some of it more advanced my
sequel features so in this case what you
want to do is have your cloud sequel
instance and you want to add some read
replicas so cloud sequel offers you the
ability to add as many read replicas as
you want for your master instance and
then at the application layer you would
want to shard your write traffic and
your read traffic so all of your write
traffic would go to your master node so
you could scale up to the max number of
requests max number of write operations
that you can put the race single GCE VM
which is what cloud sequel second
generation uses under the hood and then
add read replicas to meet the amount of
read traffic that you have so this
basically gives you a certain level of
horizontal scalability to split your
write workloads and your read workloads
again all of this is fully managed for
you if something happens to you read
replica google site reliability
engineers will fix it if something
happens to your master
since then we will take your failover
instance set it up to be readwrite and
then move the IP address over so if
you'll have the minimum amount of
downtime you don't have to do anything
this all happens for you automatically
it's all part of the managed service
that Google Offers for Google Cloud
Storage some in Turin things about cloud
cloud sequel second-generation we
released it in December of last year
it's currently in beta it is our our
fully managed my sequel service it's
three and a half nines of availability
and one of the things we just released
that we're very excited about is hot bro
so what's great about this is in the
situation where you've gone from a
gigabyte to a terabyte let's say that
you only specified two gigabytes of
storage for your my sequel instance now
if you were rolling your own instance
and had to wanted to increase the amount
of disk you'd have to create a new
instance or shut down your instance
create a snapshot of your persistent
disk volume mount bring up a new PD
volume with that snapshot reattach it to
the VM and then you could continue going
but that obviously requires a lot of
work and actually create some downtime
with hot gril on cloud sequel you can
literally go from ten gigabytes to 100
gigabytes to a terabyte all the way up
to 10 terabytes with no downtime on the
VM so you can dynamically increase the
amount of capacity that you need for
cloud sequel and for your my sequel
instance without having any downtime so
we're doing the best that we can to keep
you from having to make any decisions
upfront and allowing you the flexibility
to increase your capacity to meet
whatever load that you have
so now no sequel so if you're going down
the no sequel path again the
architecture looks remarkably similar
you've got a number of websites mobile
applications speaking to your app engine
app and then you're showing all of your
data in datastore now some things that
you should think about in datastore once
you're starting to get above a gigabyte
of data and you're starting to get to
more meaningful amounts of data
datastore offers you a number of
features that helps with your
performance it allows you to tune so
things like setting up composite indexes
and and doing other maintenance things
that you can do to look at do I need
indexes what does my traffic look like
what is the performance of my traffic
what kind of characteristics am i seeing
and starting to use some of the more
advanced features of datastore to tweak
the application to get better
performance out of it again the
beautiful thing about datastore is you
don't have to choose anything ahead of
time you don't have to say I'm planning
you know this application is gonna go
viral and I need a terabyte of data you
just say I need a place to store some
data you drop the data in and you just
keep putting data in that application
and we will make sure that we are
provisioned very somewhat App Engine to
handle the load so there's no
pre-thought on datastore it's a it's a
really wonderful thing to be able to
just get started without making any
decisions ahead of time and datastore
will work with you to then scale up your
data to whatever the size your
application Cloud datastore fully
managed no sequel service so it is again
I try to position and talk about it as a
document store type use case there's no
schema you drop data in we do some
inference on the data to make it easy to
store and make it as performant as
possible but it is different than cloud
sequel so cloud sequel is a dedicated
resource system when you say this is my
VM this is my compute and so you can do
whatever you want to that capacity with
datastore it's a multi-tenant system and
so when you are using the system we put
certain limitations in place to make
sure that all of your queries are fast
so it's really designed to have low
latency fast performance all the time
with again no forethought you don't have
to worry about schema design you don't
have to worry about creating indexes
we're gonna do as much of that as we
possibly can automatically for you so
that the application will scale once you
put data into it
all right now we're starting to get a
little bit more interesting so now we're
starting into more than a terabyte so if
you have more than a terabyte of data
you're generating some interesting
amounts of data and this is where a lot
of the talks that we've had today lead
to so when we talk about some of the the
Spotify use case and some of the other
ones it's all about how are they
aggregating lots and lots of data right
if you're talking about Internet of
Things and IOT and sensor data where do
you take all of that sensor data which
is essentially a timestamp and an
identifier and a value where do you drop
all that data in a single place with
super high read throughput so that you
can then do table scans on it and get
some data get some value out of it later
so this is where cloud BigTable is where
is what I'm really excited about for
this use case so three different ways
that you can think about using cloud
BigTable so first of all at the device
level and again this could be an IOT
device it could be a device running
brillo or weave or whatever you happen
to be using and it's pushing telemetry
data back to the system now the way that
it pushes data back to the system is it
pushes the data to pub/sub so every
reading is a single message on pub/sub
and what's great about pub/sub is it's
this globally available message queue
that allows you to push data to it from
anywhere so that device could literally
be any it doesn't have to be anywhere
near data center it could be an
individual mobile device or IOT device
it pushes the data back to pub/sub for
asynchronous processing once that
message gets into pub/sub it's durable
it's not like running your own message
queue software on a VM it's globally
available and again Google site reliable
of engineers are making sure that that's
always up and running the other thing
that's great about it and this is a
recurring theme is that you don't have
to provision it you don't have to say I
need a thousand queries per second of
capacity you can just throw data at it
and as long as your data as long as the
number of requests that you're sending
are lower than millions of QPS right
this is something that we can handle
just because all of Google runs on the
same infrastructure so when you're
sending messages to pub/sub you're using
the same infrastructure that Google uses
for all of our asynchronous processing
and you can be confident that the system
is not gonna fall over if you need to
push us a petabyte of data you can have
very high confidence that we're gonna be
able to handle that because we have lots
of experiencing handing that much data
both for our our internal applications
as well as our other customer
applications so once those messages get
into pub/sub how do you process them and
get them into cloud BigTable one example
again there's many ways to do this it's
data flow so you can use data flow to
then pick up those messages do any
transformations do any enriching
whatever you want to do either in a
batch or a stream mode and push that
data in the cloud BigTable so that's one
way to do it you could do this also with
data proc if you have an apache spark
job that you want to use for streaming
if you have a MapReduce job that you
want to use in your Hadoop cluster or
that you've been using on Prem that you
want to use in the cloud both of those
provide you the ability to then take
that data from pub/sub and drop it into
the cloud BigTable other ways that you
can do this so if you have a web device
or if you have a web application
speaking to a VM where your hosting
application that VM can speak directly
to cut a big table so you can write
directly from X number of VMs into cloud
BigTable another pattern that we see
very commonly is micro service
architecture so if you have a number of
mobile apps and those mobile apps are
all speaking back to a micro service or
a restful endpoint you often need to
collect monitoring data from those this
might be an event user clicked a song to
play in the Spotify use case or user
clicked a link or user shut the
application or open the application all
of that needs to be recorded so now from
the micro service you could push into
pub/sub and then data flow in a big
table or you can push directly into
BigTable it all depends on what your
load is and what your architecture wants
to look like what's great about this is
that once you get the data in the cloud
BigTable you have a lot of possibilities
so Cloud BigTable is our fully managed
no sequel wide column Service Cloud
BigTable in BigTable internally and the
BigTable white paper spawned much of the
the Hadoop ecosystem that we have today
and so cloud BigTable actually allows
you to use the original cloud BigTable
internal service that much of Google
still runs on today we expose it via an
HBase client
so we provide an HBase client that you
can use to integrate with your
applications that expect HBase client
but what's really interesting about
cloud BigTable and this is something we
spend a lot of time talking about is
while it is a we expose it as an HBase
client it is not HBase and what's
interesting about that is it's
incredibly low latency random reads and
writes and what this means is that even
though it's meant to work in the HBase
analytics space latencies are such that
you can actually serve live application
data out of this so you can actually
with a like 6 millisecond latency in and
out you can serve a live application
data out of here which is something that
most people wouldn't want to do out of
self-managed HBase very interesting as
well we're seeing a lot of people that
are currently managing large HBase and
Cassandra clusters this is an
interesting option for them if they want
to manage service if you don't want to
roll your own and manage your own
clusters this is a really interesting
option for people to move those
workloads over and to have them in a
fully managed service where Google s
eries are looking after your data the
other thing that I do think that I'm
also very excited about is a trend that
we're seeing externally that we've seen
inside Google for many years is this
concept of H tap which is hybrid
transactional analytics processing and
the idea here is that you can keep your
application data in the same place that
you do your analytics queries and it
doesn't require you to ETL the data into
multiple data centers doing
transformations you can leave all the
data in a single place and run your
applications from it as well as run your
analytics queries so obviously this
greatly simplifies the architecture of
an application and what's great about
this is that this is what we've doing
inside of Google for many years BigTable
bigquery things that allow us to
basically have single solutions that
allow us to run our applications as well
as doing our analytics queries and cloud
BigTable is a perfect example of how
Google's internal use case is starting
to manifest itself externally two of the
things to look at very excited a partner
Pythian recently introduced open TS DB
support for a cloud BigTable so if you
are look
for a very well adopted API for doing
time series data open TST be on top of
cloud BigTable is a really interesting
solution all right so the talk is only
supposed to go up to petabytes but we're
Google so we have to talk about exabytes
so if you've gone past exabytes or if
you've gotten past petabytes of data and
you're in approaching towards an extra
byte of data how would you go about
doing that so first question is how
would you actually get that data into
Google so we'll talk a little bit about
data injection and how we are helping
customers get that data from either on
Prem or other locations on to Google
Cloud storage so the first one is the
transfer service so we offer Google
Cloud transfer service and this is a
tool for helping to move around your
data so if you wanted to backup all of
your s3 data into a GCS bucket you can
do that and set up a schedule with
transfer service if you want to move all
move your data from a GCS bucket that a
Google Cloud Storage bucket that's
currently in standard and after 30 days
you want to move data into a GCS bucket
which is Nearline then you can do that
using transfer service so we provide
that as a tool that allows people to
help people move that data around we're
also trying to engage really hard with
our partner ecosystem we really want to
enable our partners and help our
partners help our customers get this
data into the system so first one is the
offline ingest so we work with Iron
Mountain in the US for offline ingest
and prime focus in abroad for helping
people do offline ingest
so if you have petabytes of data or even
lots of terabytes of data that you want
to get moved in the system you can put
them into a hard drive and you can ship
those to Iron Mountain and they will
upload those data that data into Google
Cloud storage for you same thing in
outside the United States the other area
that we really invested in since we
invented since we announced Nearline
last year was the filer and the
on-premise file systems so in the middle
of last year we announced the ability of
Nearline so within Google Cloud
storage we now have three different
storage classes the first one is
standard which is what people have been
using to static to host their static web
content and when they're using their
data processing pipelines durable
reduced availability which in exchange
for a slightly lower SLA of availability
you get a price break which is our
second class and then the third one we
introduced last year is near line and
near line is our warm storage archival
solution that allows you to put your
data into a GC GC a GCS bucket with near
line for basically archival and as part
of that we've been working with all of
our partners in the space to help
facilitate that for customers a lot of
these partners have huge cost of huge
enterprise footprints on-premise and
they want to be able to back up their
files to the cloud so how do we enable
that and make it easy for customers to
do that so working with the customers
like NetApp CommVault emc aveer making
sure that when you are running those
appliances on Prem or some of them in a
cloud appliance there is the option for
you to then push that data into Google
Cloud storage so that you can back it up
and again have Google's esterase looking
after your data to make sure that it is
safe and secure and always there when
you need it the last one that I would
like to talk about is data pipeline so
we've talked a little bit about this
earlier so great I've got 500 petabytes
of data in Google Cloud storage now what
it's been sitting on pram I've never
done anything with it like what is the
value to me and most people just want it
as optionality in case of a disaster
right they either need to keep it from a
compliance point of view or they just
want to make sure there's something
happens they have a copy their data
what's so great about this integrated
data platform approach is that once you
get your data into the system we can
provide lots of interesting tools for
you to be able to then take that data
and derive value from it so first one we
talked a little bit about earlier is
data flow so if you want to either do
batch or streaming and we just recently
pushed this into Apache as Apache beam
you can use data flow to run large batch
or stream processes over your 500
petabytes of data to basically clean it
extract value Tran
formant push it into bigquery do
whatever you need to do with it
and again fully managed service if you
need one petabyte of data or 500 pen
types of data it's the same code it's
running the same in the same
infrastructure the same set of api's so
we can scale ibly go through your data
and help you derive value the second one
is data proc and there's another talk
just after this one on data proc which I
encourage you guys to attend so dana
proc is really helping customers that
are running large on Prem Hadoop
installations to be able to easily move
those workloads to the cloud so if you
have a MapReduce job that you've been
running on Prem once you push all that
data into Google Cloud Storage you want
to be able to run that MapReduce so data
proc allows you to just bring that
MapReduce into Google cloud platform and
run that MapReduce over your 500
petabytes of data to get whatever value
or extraction data extracted out of that
information and then many of these if
you're doing that information if you're
doing that processing and trying to
extract the value you often need a place
to put that data so many times people
are running these dataflow jobs and data
probes and pushing data into bigquery
into a data warehouse where they can
then run their distributed queries
another thing that I'm very excited
about the direction we're going which
really speaks to the idea that you can
put your data anywhere and will help you
drive value is within bigquery you can
actually do federated queries so you can
do queries against your data that's
already in bigquery but you can also do
joins in queries against your data in
GCS so if you have your data in an Avro
or Park a file in GCS you can run
bigquery queries against that data and
potentially join it with data that you
have in bigquery but where this becomes
really interesting is that we can then
expand those federico aires out to cloud
BigTable and data store and all these
other areas so that regardless of where
your data is you don't have to ETL it
and move it into another solution and
you don't have to ETL it into and by ETL
is extract transform and load you don't
have to have a process to move that data
into bigquery you can just do the
queries from bigquery and query your
data in line so that's where it starts
to get really compelling where wherever
your data is in the Google cloud
platform
you'll be able to then access that data
and drive value from it without having
to move it around and worry about where
it is one other thing
so in data proc so if you're using a
base we have HBase connectors so you use
that as an intermediate point in data
proc also connectors for data flow so
making sure that all of these various
products work really well against Google
Cloud Storage to make it really easy to
move your files around and then no talk
about the Google cloud platform would be
complete without talking about our
marketplace solutions so in our
marketplace solutions we're working with
a great bunch of partners so that if one
of these managed solutions aren't the
right answer for you then we're working
with our partners to make sure that
there is something available to you that
will hopefully meet your needs so I've
highlighted some here we've been working
with MongoDB so that they're available
in the marketplace so if you need a
MongoDB cluster you can do that
enterprise DB for if you need Postgres
currently we don't offer Postgres in
cloud sequel and so if you want to spin
up a Postgres cluster you can do so
through enterprise DB if you're looking
to run Cassandra because maybe your
development team has a lot of experience
with Cassandra we offer a easy place for
you to take that data and spin up a
cassandra either single node or cluster
to be able to use that and same thing
with Redis so if you need Redis for your
application we provide the ability for
you to spin up a GCE Google compute
engine VM with Redis so you can then
immediately start using them in your
application so just to finish up you
know data is everything it's at the core
of everything we do we talk about a lot
of these applications and there's
amazing things you can do with machine
learning and as you start to build your
own models you're going to need a place
to actually store your data so where do
you put your training data it's going to
be in a GCS bucket or it's gonna be in a
big table table and so there has to be a
way to get your data into the system so
you can start to do all these amazing
things and she learning and other things
that we're talking about and so what
we're doing is really trying to make
sure that we have that unified data
platform so that you can bring your data
into Google cloud platform you can put
it in the application that makes sense
for you so that it's cost effective
it's the application or framework or
software that you're accustomed to
working with and then once you do that
we'll make it very easy for you to be
able to move it transform it and drive
the date drive value from it and we want
that to all be in one place we don't
want this to be something that you have
to think about as I talked about before
we're always trying to give you option
ality we want you to be able to choose
the solution that you think is best for
you and then as you scale up make it as
easy as possible to scale up your
application to meet the needs of your
users and your business without having
to make a bunch of decisions upfront we
don't want you to have to provision what
you're doing the future we don't want
you to have foresight into what your
company or business or use case is going
to look like we want to make it easy for
you to get up and running as quickly as
possible
and allow you to scale so your business
can be successful that's it thank you
you